有的时候我们生活在现在的这样一个和平的年代，
生活在现现在一个物质比较充沛的这样一个时代，
有的时候我们可能是在很多事情上期待值拉的太高了。
我35岁，
是在一个13县的县城，
是银行的基层员工，
我丈夫是39，
我们已经结婚十年了，
我结婚的时候是军嫂，
现在不是了，
我们有两个孩子，
女儿是8岁，
儿子快6岁了，
现在在离婚的冷静期。
我想咨询几个问题，
一是婚前有一套房子，
一直在还贷，
每个月的月供是2400，
因为一直在租嘛，
租金是1000，
他婚后还贷这一部分算不算共同财产？
算，
如果算是按2400算，
还是2400减去房租，
房租也是共同财产，
如果要算的话，
按2400算，
我们婚后还买了一套房子，
他父母出了28，
我父母出了9，
我们两个出了14，
但是现在房子已经瘪了嘛，
那这部分怎么分？
如果对方的父母和你的父母都黑不提白不提，
也没有撕破脸，
那么这个房子呢？
就是你们夫妻共同的财产，
法院在分财产的时候会考虑到他的父母出的多一点，
你的父母出的少一点。
会考虑到这个因素，
要适当的倾斜于他，
但如果说他的父母跳出来要还钱，
你的父母也跳出来要还钱的话，
其实有一个比较公平的做法，
就是把他父母的钱还了，
把你父母的钱还了，
剩下的你们两口子分，
但是这个钱好像现在如果卖掉的话，
也不足以还这个钱，
如果说卖掉也不足以还这个钱的话，
反正有两种可能性吧，
第一种可能性就是法官会判定这个房子是你们夫妻共同的财产，
但是在分割的时候会考虑到财产的来源，
对出现多的那一方会适当的照顾，
这是一种方法。
另一种方法就是可能卖了这个房子能亏一部分钱，
但是把老人的刨出去，
剩下就是你们两口子自己亏的，
就是如果说老人跳出来说这是借款关系，
就有可能两边的老人，
因为我们是借款关系，
因为我们现在是协议嘛，
现在老人也没有跳出来说，
只是他说他父母出了比较多，
那我就说就按贬值的比例这样分可以吗？
可以啊，
按当时双方父母出钱的比例，
20年因为做过一个手术，
有赔付他30个了，
这一部分钱是这是目前是他个人的，
不属于这是因为他的身体受到伤害，
得到的赔偿是跟他的身体挂钩的，
这部分钱呢，
基本上嘛，
就是损害赔偿，
这部分钱是属于他个人的，
但是如果有比如说误工费这方面的话，
就有可能是夫妻共同的了，
只要。
就跟他的身体的受伤，
身体的受伤挂钩的赔偿都是属于他个人的财产，
他离开单位的时候还拿到了一部分钱，
差不多有20多个吧，
这个是属于我们共同的，
还是他个人共同的，
离职补偿是属于共同的，
还有一些补贴什么的，
是这样，
如果他是退伍，
他退伍的时候得到的这些补偿的话，
是要按年限算，
比如说他退伍的时候，
假设我们是按20年算啊，
那么其中你跟他结婚是几年，
如果你跟他结婚是5年的话，
那么这20年当中呢，
有5年就跟你有关系，
剩下的15年就跟你没关系，
是这个意思，
如果说是错误的，
因为这些钱都混在一起了嘛，
现在我们手上我这边有37个吧现金，
还有40多股金，
这样子，
我刚才所说的那些现在都在这里边了，
我们要怎么分？
如果所有的钱都混成一锅粥了，
包括退伍的费用，
包括他赔偿得到的钱，
包括你们的工资，
甚至你婚前的钱，
如果都放在你这里，
都混成一锅粥了，
那大概率下是要平分的。
在平分的基础之上，
如果说人家能够证明当时他的退伍费是多少钱，
你们结婚的年限是多长时间，
如果对方能够证明当时他的赔偿款是多少钱，
那可能也会对他倾向性的照顾一些，
即便是所有的钱都放在一起了。
那反而也会考虑到这些钱的来源来自于什么，
也会对他适当照顾一些吧，
因为我们当时买的租金是溢价买的嘛，
但是他现在的价值已经不足那么多了，
我们是按现在的价值分嘛，
还是按现在的价值分啊，
夫妻两口子分财产都是按照现在的价值，
比如说房子以前买的时候是100万，
现在值50万，
那么分的时候按50万分，
比如说车子买的时候是30万，
现在只值10万块钱，
那么我们分手的时候就按10万块钱的现在的价值分，
包括股权也是啊，
股金可能你买的时候100万，
现在只剩30万了，
就按30万分，
我的公积金账户还有一些钱，
那这个怎么算？
在你们结婚的这个年限之内的公积金都属于夫妻共同的财产，
你可以分他的，
他也可以分你的，
好，
现在我们两个是商定嘛，
我们两个孩子我都带着他公司的一半作为抚养费，
那我想说，
比如说孩子因为现在补习啊，
当然我不希望他生病啊，
或者生病这些大的支出我可以再跟他另外再要嘛，
可以你们在离婚协议的时候就应该写明白，
白纸黑字的写孩子现在的抚养费是多少钱，
如果将来孩子发生重大的医疗支出，
意外的支出，
重大的比如说留学的费用，
或者是读大学的费用，
你们也可以到时候再平摊，
这个也是可以写明。
的，
那这个就是平摊是吗？
不是说按照我们工司的比例，
因为我工资比他较少，
这个是可以约定的，
比如说以后的医疗支出按照一个比例来分摊也是可以的，
法律也是允许的。
好我还想问一下，
因为我女儿她比较敏感吗？
我什么实际告诉他比较好，
女儿是8岁对不对？
对两个孩子的归你是吗？
对，
我方便问一下你为什么要跟他分开吗？
她也没有什么实质性的问题吧，
只是我觉得跟他在一起很累，
因为我每次都想要解决问题，
他总是冷暴力，
我跟你讲啊，
姐妹啊，
如果说男方没有什么实质性的问题没有，
比如说C呀，
我呀，
找2+1呀，
在外面欠钱呀，
或者说其他的任何的恶习呀，
其实我建议你这个事情可以缓一缓，
我非常建议你去看一些战争片，
比如说看一下战长沙，
呃，
看一下以前那些年代片，
我特别建议你去做这个事情，
我自己的感受是什么呢？
有的时候我们生活在现在的这样一个和平的年代，
生活在现现在一个物质比较充沛的这样一个时代，
有的时候我们可能是在很多事情上期待值拉的太高了，
我真心的啊，
姐妹啊，
我觉得你这个事情先放一放，
不要着急去走那一步，
即便是到了你近期，
只要你不配合的话，
咱们也暂时离不了，
我真心的建议所有的姐妹们。
都去看一看这种啊，
类似于战争片吧，
比如说战长沙呀，
除了战长沙，
可能还有比较好的一些战争片，
大家都可以去看一看，
看完了这些了之后，
再回过来想我今天此时此刻拥有的这些生活，
儿女都很健康，
老公也能挣钱，
虽然说他可能责任心没有那么强，
不怎么管事儿，
但他对我的家庭是有贡献的，
是有价值的。
幸福这个事情最终还是要向内求，
就是你们除了要看战争片，
看战长沙这样的电视剧之外，
最好是多听一听被讨厌的勇气这样的书，
用3个月的时间吧，
就干这件事情，
二三年的时候其实就已经到冷静期了，
他那时候说可以试着改变一下我们的相处模式，
我们其实也沟通了很多，
我发现我们对于很多事情的观念是不一样的，
我觉得反而分开这一个月冷静期嘛，
他反而会更多的去照顾一下孩子，
其实我本身对他没有太多的那种期望了，
我只是希望他多一点时间陪孩子，
但是我感觉很难，
其实我非常坦率的告诉你，
姐妹啊，
这个事情呢，
我自己也经历过，
这种看男的横看不顺眼，
竖看不顺眼，
我觉得他对孩子的付出比得上我的1/10都不到，
他对孩子的那个牵挂，
他对孩子那个关心，
他比不上我真实的这种心境的转变供你参考，
我现在的想法是我生的孩子。
我关心他，
我爱他，
这就是我心目中的自己该有的样子。
这个孩子是他的，
他在孩子小的时候不陪伴，
不关心，
不操心，
将来孩子跟他的缘分也就浅，
将来孩子对他也就没有太深的眷恋，
这是他和孩子之间的单线的缘分。
我不再强求说我的对象一定要跟我一样去陪孩子游泳，
陪孩子去玩游戏，
陪孩子去游乐场，
陪孩子去爬山，
不岂感，
为什么？
因为我觉得他和孩子之间的缘分是他们俩的事儿，
我和孩子之间的缘分是我俩的事儿，
在我还有能力有时间去好好的去陪伴孩子的时候，
我就去陪伴孩子，
为什么？
因为我陪伴孩子我高兴，
我看到孩子吃什么东西吃的可香了，
我高兴，
孩子会反馈给我，
会反哺给我很多幸福的元素和瞬间，
这个就很好了，
我不期待说他爸一定要像我一样的认真负责，
一定要像我一样的上心，
一要像我一样的给孩子陪伴。
我不期待，
从我不期待那一刻开始的话，
我跟我对象也就不再有什么矛盾。
但是我总是想说，
孩子在这样的环境下会好吗？
女而负责，
他们长大以后，
他们觉得婚姻就是这个样子，
婚姻本来就是这个样子的，
你不要给孩子造成一种假象，
去提高孩子的婚姻预期，
反而对孩子的幸福不利。
我这句话认真讲，
我们觉得这个逻辑只要有你认真讲，
你不要给孩子造成一种假象，
让孩子对婚姻有太高的期待。
太美好的期待，
这样反而不利，
就像那个小公爷他的老婆，
他说可能是我爸爸妈妈太恩爱了吧，
我跟小公爷就在一起的时候，
总觉得应该像爸爸妈妈那样的相处才对，
不是我跟你说，
像我们这样的平凡夫妻才是常态，
像你老公那样的都怎么管孩子才是常态，
有多少姐妹有同感的，
就是你明显的感觉孩子他爸对孩子的投入没有你一半，
对孩子的投入他铁定不如我，
那就别说一半都赶不上我1/3，
都赶不上我1/5，
但是常态，
这是正常现象。
他总是贬低我，
就从一开始到现在，
他还觉得我留下给他是我这辈子最大的福气，
你长着嘴，
这福气给你，
你要不要就你长着嘴呢？
别让自己委委屈屈的啊。
我就一直在吃委屈，
这几年我才忽然发现，
我不是他说的那样，
也没有，
就是你如果想要跟他分开，
我刚才跟你讲的这些法律上的怎么分，
你心里有数了是不是？
其实我觉得你现在之所以会委屈，
之所以是会哭会难受，
就表示你还没有心死，
如果有一天你真的心死了，
你真的决绝的跟他分开了，
你会非常冷静的问我财产怎么分，
你不会难受，
不会委屈，
委屈之所以难受，
现在你心没有死，
既然你心没有死的情况下，
你就按照我说的做，
去看看战争片，
去听一听被讨厌的勇气，
去研究一下这本书，
我自己家有个亲戚，
她也是，
哎，
跟我聊起来的时候委屈的哭，
说她老公对这。
不好，
那不好的，
自从她听我的话，
她研究了被讨厌的勇气这本书了之后，
我推荐她听撒娇宝典的课，
她去听了之后，
她幡然醒悟，
她想想我觉得这些年这男的也挺不容易的啊，
我好像也并没有真的爱过她，
没有真正的尊重过她，
没有真正的心疼过她，
打个飞机回去要跟她老公复合，
真的没骗你吗？
我建议你也是这样，
我们这一次爆发是因为她本来是答应晚上回来给孩子陪她嘛，
但后面她因为事情没有回来，
打电话刚开始还接，
后面不接了，
他一直2点才回来，
我没因为这个吵，
他就一直骂我，
我就推他，
他就还手，
他其实是打了我的，
就这么算两下，
我觉得还会再有的，
行，
那我就不劝你了啊，
别的还有什么问题吗？
没有好，
首先要对自己好啊，
跟孩子也别发脾气，
你跟他离了之后，
他可能再婚再生孩子，
他的财产会被稀释，
你要有心理准备，
比如说他现在答应一个月拿一半的工资给你，
等他有了新的老婆，
有了新的孩子，
他不可能给你，
那么你拿到的可能也就一两千块钱，
你要有心理准备啊，
好，
那就这样啊，
但是不管怎么说，
姐妹啊，
我刚刚推荐你看的电视剧你看，
我推荐你听新的课你去听，
我推荐你看的书你去研究，
这对你有好处，
你相信我菲姐懂妹们，
我是属于那种超会安慰自己的人，
我超会让自己开心，
超会让自己找到解脱的人，
我不管遇到什么事情的话，
我都转念一想的话，
我马上让自己高高兴兴的，
他不。
回来就不回来呗，
是他和孩子之间的失约，
孩子对他失望，
孩子又不是对我失望，
不回来，
难道孩子的作业就不做了吗？
他不回来，
难道孩子作业就不交了吗？
该吃吃，
该喝喝，
该干嘛干嘛，
该睡睡，
不回来就不回来，
记得点赞关注哦。